ja der flüchtlingsgipfel im Kanzleramt
ist ein vollkommener Reinfall gewesen
hat sich da auf minimal Lösungen
verständlich die eigentlich keine
richtigen Lösung sind es gibt eine
Milliarde mehr vom Bund für die Länder
für die Unterbringung von Flüchtlingen
aber man macht weiterhin die Grundfehler
dass man eigentlich diese Migration von
100.000 Menschen in unser Land diese
nicht abreißenden Strom auffasst
eigentlich als eine Herausforderung für
die Bürokratie in Wahrheit ist das aber
ja eine historische Ausnahme Situation
die in der wir sind es ist nicht normal
dass so viele Menschen einfach so
ungesteuert in unser Land kommen und da
müsste man ansetzen deswegen appelliere
ich an die Politik klar kommen mit der
Realität die Abschiebungen funktionieren
vielfach so nicht es ist unrealistisch
dass man erst im Land wenn die Menschen
da sind den Aufenthaltsstatus sozusagen
klärt das muss vorher gemacht werden
dann muss an den Außengrenzen Geschehen
deswegen vollkommen klar mein Appell die
Politik muss ein Job Signal senden und
sagen wie helfen echten Flüchtlingen
aber wir stehen zum Asylrecht zum
Missbrauch des
Asylrechts deswegen ganz klar macht euch
nicht auf den Weg ihr werdet Deutschland
nicht zu eurer Heimat machen das müsste
sich mal jemand trauen aus der Politik
zu sagen denn sonst wird nur das erleben
wir gerade die AFD gestärkt übrigens was
glauben Sie in allen Medien wird dieser
flüchtlingsgipfel als Reinfall
beschrieben warum hat sich die Politik
da so schwer und tut sich immer noch so
schwer ganz konkrete Maßnahmen zu
beschließen sich dazu einigen
das fragen Sie am besten diejenigen die
dafür Verantwortung tragen ja ich finde
es traurig ehrlich gesagt denn
ich selber bin viel im Ausland unterwegs
und kenne sozusagen auch Miseren die im
Ausland stattfinden bin selber auch mit
einer ausländischen Frau verheiratet
glücklich seit 16 Jahren und mir geht es
viel zu wenig um Integration und
Einbeziehung und Zukunft mitzugestalten
für all diejenigen die hier sind und das
ist übrigens auch ein Thema was wir
vorher hatten mit den Schulen da Spiel
natürlich ganz erheblich auch da eine
Rolle sie haben gesagt fragen Sie doch
die die Verantwortung tragen das machen
wir direkt nämlich hier Busen sind neben
mir die FDP ihre Partei regiert mit man
hat das Gefühl die FDP macht so ein
bisschen mit dabei Probleme von der
einen Seite wieder zur anderen Seite zu
wälzen wie lange will man das noch
weitermachen also leider ist das so und
was ich ein großes Problem finde in
Deutschland ist wirklich ein offenes
Land wir haben es erlebt als die
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine kam wie
vorher sie empfangen worden sind die
Deutschen wollen wirklich helfen das ist
eine aber das Problem ist sie ihre
reguläre Einwanderung sie haben es
gerade angeschnitten genau das ist das
Problem wir müssen wirklich bei den
Abschiebungen härter durchgreifen es
nützt alles nicht so human zu sein und
noch humaner zu sein die Demokratie wird
gefehlt die Leute werden unruhig und wir
sind praktisch mit dafür verantwortlich
dass dann Parteien aus den rechten und
den linken Rändern stärker werden und da
ist ja noch eine größere Gefahr wir
müssen wirklich an den außen Menschen
beginnen die Außengrenzen sichern und
wir müssen auch an den Außengrenzen die
Leute
aufnehmen und sagen so hier Stopp du
kannst hier rein und du nicht wir reden
auch immer als Freie Demokraten vom
System Kanada wir wollen nach
kanadischen nach kanadischen Vorbild wir
machen es aber leider nicht und dann
müssen wir jetzt wirklich ran oder wird
jetzt auch was passieren ist die FDP da
die stark genug dahinter sie sind in der
Regierung sie können genau das machen
was sie jetzt gerade gesagt den Eindruck
da ist nicht genug PS hinten drauf ja
man hat den Eindruck aber es ist PS
genug drauf wir machen sehr viel Druck
ein koalitionsfahrer bei uns ist dann
schwierig das Spiel ein bisschen
Ideologie der Rolle und so weiter ich
meine jetzt die Grünen klar das ist
unser schwieriger Partner natürlich weil
wir haben wirklich komplett andere
Einstellungen wir freie soziale
Marktwirtschaft Freiheit und so weiter
bei den Grünen ist ein bisschen anders
und wir machen aber jetzt tatsächlich
Druck dass wir wirklich mit den
Abschiebung Vorankommen wir haben jetzt
einen migration
beauftragten
installiert und da werden wir jetzt
Druck machen und auch wir werden auch
Druck machen dass wir die Außengrenzen
sichern dass wird passieren außer Moos
passieren gerade wurde das Thema
Abschiebungen angesprochen vielfach wird
kritisiert es funktioniert ja einfach
auch seit Jahren nicht da kommt man
einfach nicht weiter ja es hat ja ganz
verschiedene Ursachen also es geht ja
damit los dass die Herkunftsländer ihre
Staatsangehörigen teilweise nicht
zurücknehmen mitunter auch weil es sich
wie im Fall von Anis im Attentäter von
Bereitschaft zum einen natürlich
Problemfall hatte wo man sagt dann müsst
ihr uns erstmal nachweisen dass das
unsere Straftäter gestartet und unser
Staatsangehöriger ist das ein Problem
für mich auch nicht haben ist natürlich
ein Problem wenn solche Leute ohne Pass
eingereist sind damit geht es los das
zweite ist natürlich dann dieses ganze
Chaos zwischen den Ämtern man hat ja
auch immer Digitalisierung gesprochen da
muss müssen die koordiniert werden
aber auch das wird nicht reichen das
muss man ganz klar sagen sondern ist
muss eben der Zuzug in unser Land muss
reguliert werden es dürfen dann
bestimmte Menschen die auch gar Recht
haben die wieder Asylgründe haben die
auch das wird ja auch immer vermengt
dieses Thema wir brauchen so und so viel
100.000 Fachkräfte mag ja sein die
Menschen die übers Asylsystem kommen
sind aber keine Fachkräfte und das der
sozusagen ein ökonomischer Nutzen soll
ja eigentlich bei Asyl auch gar keine
Rolle spielen sondern geht um Schutz
erstmal so das wird immer vermengt in
der Diskussion ist ein Problem deswegen
muss eben dazu zu geregelt werden und
das passiert nicht die Abschiebung
alleine sind da nicht das Allheilmittel
um das zu lösen das erleben wir ja wie
gesagt
die FDP große Worte haben wir gehört und
trotzdem hat man den Eindruck dass in
der Regierung es so an so vielen Ecken
knirscht und knarzt und man sich
überhaupt nicht einig wird hier wurde
auch gerade ganz klar der
Koalitionspartner angesprochen die
Grünen man fragt sich wie lange macht
die FDP noch mit ja da fragen wir doch
am besten aber ich denke mal ich denke
mal sehr lange wenn sie es noch
mitmachen nach dem Motto oh wie schön
ist Kanada kann man natürlich auch ein
Asylrecht nicht reformieren und wir
haben ja zwei Dinge gesehen die sollten
vielleicht noch mal sachlich darauf
zurückkommen einmal warum haben die
ganzen Ministerpräsidenten wie gesagt ja
oder mehr war nicht drin und wir haben
zugestimmt das haben sie ja also getan
gestern außer so ein paar
protokollerklärungen da kennen sich die
FDP ja mit aus und wo sie gesagt haben
wir nicht dabei einmal weißen Einschlag
Einstieg gab in die Finanzierung durch
Bund und Länder der Bund hat ja gesagt
immer es war Ländersache jetzt haben sie
gesagt es ist eine dauerhafte Aufgabe
von Bund und Ländern das heißt es ist
ein Einstieg und ein Arbeitsgruppe und
auch viel verlacht wurde eingerichtet um
zu klären in welcher Form und eine
Milliarde haben die Länder gesagt na ja
die nehmen wir schon mal mit aber wir
haben ja ein ganz anderes Problem und
insofern ist es auch nicht ganz
wie soll ich das sagen klar wenn man
sagt ja die müssen alle draußen bleiben
oder keine Ahnung die die nicht
anerkannt werden auch wir nehmen ja wir
haben natürlich eine ein Anstieg jetzt
schon um 78 % in diesem Jahr in den
ersten vier Monate haben wir glaube ich
100.000 knapp über 100.000 Anträge auf
Asyl bekommen in Deutschland das ist ähm
78% mehr als letztes Jahr in dem
gleichen Zentrum aber 70 Prozent werden
anerkannt also er kann man nicht sagen
das sind als Leute die nicht anerkannt
werden da muss man sich fragen
vielleicht unter welchen Kriterien was
sind die Gründe dafür die meisten von
ihnen kommen tatsächlich aus Afghanistan
sagen sie kommen aus Syrien und sonst
wenn zusätzlich zu den einem mehr als
einen Millionen Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine also das stimmt ja offenbar was
nicht wenn man nur sagt die müssen
draußen bleiben wir brauchen mehr
Außengrenze und 70% finden hier
Anerkennung da frage ich mich wo ist da
hier der Fehler im System das fragen
sich viele und viele fragen sich warum
findet die Bundesregierung nicht den
Fehler im System wenn man sie schon
zusammensetzt und sich auch auf die
Suche nach den Fehlern und den Lösungen
begibt warum tut man sich da so schwer
selber es gibt ja ganz bemerken es
werden Paradigmenwechsel muss man sagen
in diesem Beschluss das ist jetzt
erstmals auch tatsächlich heiß und zwar
von einer sozusagen rot grün dominierten
sorry für die FDP aber rote nominierten
Ampel Bundesregierung das jetzt erstmals
gesagt wird die irreguläre Migration ist
zu begrenzen das ist wenn man das vor
fünf Jahren gesagt hat da wurde
angeschaut als wäre man quasi mit einem
Bein im Rechtsextremismus das war ja so
das war das so wurde anders immer
vorgehalten jetzt ist sozusagen diese
Erkenntnis endlich durch die Kraft des
Faktischen sozusagen eingesunken jetzt
scheitert es aber immer noch leider an
der Lösungen und ich sehe noch nicht äh
das also jetzt haben wir sozusagen das
Problem endlich mal auch beschrieben
akkurat jetzt muss die Politik aber
wirklich kommen also vielleicht muss man
auch mal nachdenken ob man den Leuten
Geld gibt oder ob man den Sachleistungen
gibt
es funktioniert auch was nützt das wenn
man den Leuten Bürgergeld und alles
mögliche geben und das Geld wird auch
teilweise dann zurück in die in deren
Länder geschickt wenn wir mit
Sachleistungen helfen also es soll ja
geholfen werden und dann ist eine
Wohnung eine Heizung Wasser
ein bisschen aus haben Sie den Eindruck
des Deutschland auch zu viele Anreize
bietet ja natürlich ich höre das ja auch
von Krankenhäusern und Ärzten wie die
Leute dann auch behandelt werden als
wäre es privatpatienten werden und der
ganz normale Bürger denkt wieso muss ich
so lange warten und der bekommt gleich
einen Termin beim Arzt das sind alle
solche Dinge die auch in der
Gesellschaft dann zu Unzufriedenheit
führen das ist auch hoch kann ich dann
gefährlich man kann diese Menschen mit
Sachleistung eindecken die müssen keinen
Bargeld haben bisschen Taschengeld ist
kein Problem
das derzeit über vieles gesprochen wird
das machen wir auch hier gerade in
dieser Runde und die Erwartungen an den
flüchtlingsgipfel waren groß ich glaube
viele Menschen erwarten dass man jetzt
auch ins Handeln kommt finden Sie in
einer Selbstkritik jetzt auch mal wie
gesagt ihre Partei in der Regierung drin
tut man da genug kommt man genug ins
Handeln kann aber nicht genug getan und
das wird sich jetzt ändern weil die
Situation ist so angespannt wir können
es einfach nicht mehr schaffen so und
deswegen wird auch was getan bin ich
ganz fest von überzeugt dass auch unsere
Partei dass wir da jetzt auch uns
bewegen und auch den unseren Partnern
sagen so geht es jetzt nicht weiter wir
müssen so und so jetzt handeln wie wir
das gesagt haben und wenn Sie das ihren
Partner sagen und die machen nicht mit
verlässt dann die FDP die Regierung also
wir werden jetzt nicht die Regierung
gleich verlassen streit gehört dazu wir
streiten uns konstruktiv
und wir haben auch einiges ja auch schon
auf dem Weg gebracht und erreicht und
gut dass sie auch dabei sind
sie sagen nicht gleich aber das würde
mich interessieren was sind da für sie
wie würden sie das Einschätzen die
Kipppunkte wo muss aus ihrer sich die
FDP sagen bis dahin aber dann machen wir
nicht mehr also wenn was der
Gesellschaft nicht mehr
zumuten können das ist immer so
weitergeht dann geht das nicht mehr da
muss man sagen diese Regierung kann so
nicht weitermachen aber das der Punkt
der ist ja noch nicht erreicht wir sind
auf der Kippe und wenn wir die Menschen
nicht mitnehmen im Lande da kommen wir
gleich auch noch mal dazu dann haben wir
verloren die das Vertrauen in der
Politik darf nicht noch weiter verloren
gehen das ist leider ist es so und wir
stärken nur linke und rechte Ränder und
dann müssen dann ganz vorsichtig sein
dass er jetzt wirklich handeln würden
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie